Saturn's insane Powers the fate of Luffy
and kizaru a super hype God Valley
flashback and even a Luffy's mom reveal
after 1,100 chapters pretty much all of
that craziness will get into in this
chapter so make sure you stay tuned for
that chill paring within and smash that
like button if you enjoy one piece
reviews like this one I want to keep
them coming make this the video you join
the knock them up by subscribing hitting
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and updates if you hit
that button you're also helping us reach
our insane dream of 2 million
subscribers on YouTube which would be
much appreciated and now without further
Ado let's jump into It spoilers and all
the title we're given for chapter 1095
is a world doesn't worth living in now
we'll see the official translation when
it comes out and how it probably changes
but it seems to come down to the topic
of whether this cruel world of One Piece
as we'll see is worth living it in
spoiler alert it's tied to that insane
flashback that I mentioned but for now
let's just say We'll return to the title
later on in the chat chapter the reader
request cover page seems amusing too for
this one since it has a monkey taking
Buggy's nose and running away and
something like this is all the more
entertaining now that buggy is a yonko
love to see now yonko buggy getting some
love here now if you'll remember last
chapter's craziness consisted of Saturn
using what seems like an awakened
mythical Zone devil fruit when he was
summoned the power was so great a dude's
head blew off because he witnessed it
now if that's hockey related or fruit
related let me know your thoughts in the
comments Luffy reached his so-called
limit as well last chapter although he
did before with kaido and reactivated
gear five when he really needed to but
he didn't reach his limit before giving
kizaru a through the head punch that had
him seeing Stars so they kind of at
least temporarily took each other out of
commission from the looks of it Kizer
was taking out of commission because of
Luffy's attacks and Luffy because his
limit for using gear five was up so it
is notable here that gear five does
pretty much best kizaru but the time
limit seems to keep things interesting
here so it's not too one excited notably
Bonnie also stabbed Saturn's crazy
awakened spider demon form now as I said
last chapter this obviously wouldn't do
anything and as expected we soon
discovered that I was correct so this
chapter starts with the vice Admirals
preparing to help St Saturn a hilarious
idea in and of itself but Saturn orders
them to stand down Saturn says that he
could easily Dodge Bonnie's attack if he
would have wanted to Saturn pulls out
the sword from his body and the blood
disappears some cool spider demon
superpowers there again no surprise here
I'm sure no one thought Bonnie would
actually do some real damage but it's
notable because it let Oda reveal that
Saturn is tied to what happened to Kuma
Bonnie's dad and so OD is telling us
that the stakes of this fight are
especially big for her by the way we're
told Saturn attacks Bonnie and Sanji by
emitting Aura from his eyes Bonnie and
Sanji are knocked in the head and some
blood comes out but their heads don't
explode so crazy to see these psychic
like Powers coming from him as well
again a part of me really wonders how
much is hockey and how much is this
devil fruit power kizaru then apologizes
to Saturn notably kizaru is still on the
ground and unable to move and that's
what I guessed would be the case last
chapter it would make sense to me that
gear five Luffy could at least take kizu
out of commission for a while and so far
it looks like mission accomplished that
is a huge victory in and of itself
compared to how Untouchable kizaru
looked at sabot and we would expect
nothing less from the guy that took down
the strongest creature in the world but
the crazy thing now is that after Luffy
is out of commission we have Saturn who
definitely looks like more of a threat
than even kizaru he says to kizaru your
work is unusually slow this time since
he was probably expecting the Speedy
kizaru to take care of it without his
help again goes to show how much of an
oddity the straw hats have become Saturn
then goes to stomp Luffy but luckily our
boy Frankie extends his arm and saves
Luffy Luffy is also still conscious but
like kizaru not in great shape and
actually doesn't say anything this
chapter so unfortunately for now it
looks like Vega Punk Bonnie Sanji and
Frankie are left to deal with s pattern
so in that case it's not looking good as
if the situation didn't look Grim enough
for our side we also get Vega Punk
Bonnie Sanji and Frankie being unable to
move due to Saturn's mysterious power
looking forward to learning more about
this but it's almost like they are
caught in some invisible spiderweb and
are the helpless victims of demonic
spider Saturn of course it could also be
a kind of non-s spider web related
mythical Zone fruit power and if Saturn
can blow up people's heads then
paralyzing them shouldn't be too hard
Vega Punk also says if this is not a
scientific power then this must be a
devil fruit ability but the crazy thing
about this is that Vega Punk seemed very
well versed in Devil fruits and even the
rare NAA fruit which you can't say for
most people but he doesn't seem to
recognize this one which is crazy to
think about if it is a devil fruit then
it's clearly a very special well-kept
secret even better kept than Luffy so
much fascinating Mysteries coming up
here Saturn then grabs Bonnie and
squeezes her she says you killed my
father like it's Star Wars but but
rather than spider daddy Saturn saying I
am your father we jump to an insane
flashback first off we see Kuma telling
young Bonnie about Nika that's right
Kuma is telling his daughter Bonnie
about the myth of NAA which Luffy's
devil fruit is based off of Kuma makes
naik's drum rhythm sound and they dance
together cool to see this flashback and
this Arc tying back into Luffy's Del
fruit and the myth of naika Kuma tells
Bonnie that he wants to be a hero who
liberates people like na and this
definitely fits well with a
revolutionary like I said before Luffy
being NAA goes so well as a symbol for
the revolutionaries because he's
supposed to be a warrior of Liberation
and now Oda is emphasizing that even
more making my hope for Dragon and Luffy
to team up sooner than later even more
likely also cool how now Bonnie is with
Luffy and thus with the devil fruit
embodiment of this na myth she was told
about from a young age back to the
present for a bit and Saturn reveals
Kuma's race which is a new one it's the
buccaneer race of course in our world
Buccaneer wasn't anything crazy it was a
pirate originally off the Spanish
American coasts but here the buccaneer
people once committed a crime they also
seem to have blood of the Giants making
them unusually strong definitely makes
sense for Kuma then a new flashback
starts and it takes place 47 years ago
in the Sor Bay Kingdom Kuma was born in
a normal family and his father was a
member of the buccaneer race but like
Gohan and his connection to being a
Saiyan and Dragon Ball his mother was a
normal human so you could say that Kuma
is half Buccaneer but like with Gohan
they might just consider that a
Buccaneer anyways the information about
Kuma's blood test was leaked to a world
government agent at the hospital and
probably tied to that unnamed crime the
Buccaneers supposedly committed Kuma's
entire family was captured and became
slaves in marijua due to their strength
that makes the image of Kuma being
ridden by a Celestial Dragon decades
later so much worse now because now we
know he's been dealing with this for so
long and you start to really feel for B
and her pain after the mother's death
Kuma's dad told him about the legend of
NAA his dad said that the legend has
been passed down specifically among
bucker race members again really tying
Luffy in with the kuma and Bonnie stuff
well so I wonder if the old na that the
fruit is based on was originally a
Buccaneer too with the giant blood and
everything and that would at least help
explain why Luffy uses a giant form
sometimes or giant limbs at least other
times just like Kuma did for Bonnie his
dad made Na's drum rhythm sound and
dance for him but then shockingly and
tragically his father was suddenly shot
in the head by Celestial Dragon for
making too much noise man props to Oda
he really knows how to make our blood
boil with these Celestial Dragon
injustices he's making the eventual
toppling of them so much more satisfying
and always making that time Luffy
punched the Celestial Dragon so much
more satisfying as well we then cut to
38 years ago which was by the way the
year the god Valley incident with GARP
Roger and The Rock Pirates took place
here a Celestial Dragon explains that
every 3 years the celestial dragons come
down from Marisha and conduct a human
hunting game on a non-government island
they released problematic slaves on the
island and wiped them out along with the
native people on the island after that
the world government claims the island
as their own really messed up stuff
there the island that the celestial
dragons chose for that year was surprise
surprise God Valley this is insanely
interesting because we are supposedly
going to learn how we got from this
point to what actually happened with the
GARP and Roger and rock Pirates stuff
why did they all come and what exactly
happened there are few topics as hype as
this one in one piece so as I was saying
God Valley an island in the West Blue
was chosen the land with many valuable
resources and that dare to use the word
God in its name and obviously this has
to do with the celestial dragons wanting
to be the only gods and anything else
being Blasphemous the king of God Valley
understandably tried to stop them but
saint figar land Garling shank's
potential dad or relative killed him in
the flashback that Year's hunting game
hasn't started yet but Garling is the
one that the celestial dragons expect to
be the champion of that game a young
Garling was very handsome with his Half
Moon hair and at this point no beard
many Celestial dragons swooned over him
like he was the Beatles or something now
we get some very interesting stuff that
seems to confirm what we've been
speculating Saturn was also on God
Valley then as well and he looks exactly
the same as in the present showing that
yes he's definitely not aging Goro
definitely got that eternal life from
the looks of it or at least don't age if
they're not straight up Immortal so this
seems to be tied with what Bonnie saw
with the kuma flashback in fact Saturn
receives word that the buccaneer child
slave AKA Kuma who escaped was captured
we see Kuma being dragged in the field
by other slaves and this part is the
continuation of the flashback Bonnie saw
in chapter 1074 it's the one where a
crying Bonnie watch watch kid Kuma
saying then kill me here instead why
bother going back I'm just going to die
anyway end quote so it ties back to the
title and the idea of the cruel world
and if it's worth living in in one piece
and especially Kuma's World a mysterious
person says heha hold right there you
guys you must be the buccaneer the star
of this I see what they mean you're
indeed huge they say the blood of giants
runs within you we can then see that the
two mysterious Shadows are two child
slaves a young Ivanov and a girl named
Jenny and who would think that Jenny
would be the crazier reveal here but let
me explain for the time being Ivanov
looks pretty similar to adult appearance
and Jenny is a short-haired smiling girl
that is eating a piece of meat Jenny
says isn't my big bro here huge too
while Ivanov ansers just a face though
wait that's not the point here you dummy
end quote so here it is from the sounds
of it this is the obvious choice for
Luffy's mom and we've never gotten a
better clue for 1 th in 100 chapters
almost think about it the being with
Ivanov and Kuma here means that it's
very likely that she would meet Dragon
eventually too just like the other two
and just aside from that the meat The
Smiling the being called a dummy all
clear nods and similarities to Luffy as
well so yes this may very well be the
one piece chapter that first introduced
Luffy's mother remember this is 38 years
ago so it could definitely work math
wise as well that's arguably one of the
biggest deals in this crazy chapter and
in the series but Ivanov goes on and
talks tokuma Ivanov says tokuma I choose
to live what about you and quote so
offering a different answer to the one
Kuma offered earlier and obviously we
know that they do survive so Kuma was
likely convinced to try now I can't wait
to see how Roger GARP and The Rock
Pirates get tied up into all of this
what role they play and how everything
goes down it's also hype let me know do
you agree that this is Luffy's Mom right
here after 1,100 chapters almost let me
know in the comments we got a break next
week but if you're loving the awakened
fruit reveals lately especially
considering Saturn has one too probably
you won't want to miss my recent video
about all 14 awakened devil fruit users
and their powers explained link to that
is on screen right now like And
subscribe to help us reach our insane
goal of 2 million subscribers on YouTube
and I'll see you in the next one